is it because
it's my mom hold on
i'm trying to work right now you order
calling my phone this is the angelo you
can say hi
and don't be holding up traffic cause
you got cars behind you
[Music]
did you record that
welcome back that's the viral video of
sandy and miles harris an amazing mother
and son duo and it was seen more than 10
million times it's what they call going
viral miles is a reporter at our
affiliate abc6 in columbus ohio and when
they
visited us here in the studio they were
right here that's right there we all are
cute
well
we turned the questions on them and we
found out that sandy his mom has dreams
of being a reporter too yes and they're
reporting on their very first story
together by introducing us to an
incredible drew drew-gooder named jenna
she's the president of fairy good
mothers a non-profit that gives out free
prom dresses to girls in the community
yes
so let's make a couple dreams go too
right now we're gonna go live to them
now at the abc 6 studios hi guys
um how does it feel to be reporting
together
fantastic
i get to be the teacher today i guess
right so
here we go
here we go exactly and what a great
story too we get to meet jenna hi jenna
hi
now jenna it's so great to meet you and
we know that you volunteer i'm so
excited yes well and you've been a
volunteer in your community since middle
school
why has been giving back been so
important to you for so long
well i i felt like at that moment in
time it
it's a big deal in middle school to
realize that there are other people out
there you actually start to realize the
world is bigger than yourself
and uh when i realized that i realized
how important little moments were to
people little interactions with somebody
you don't really know what kind of
interaction you're going to have but
you can leave it a little bit better
than you started and so once i realized
that i thought i'll start to volunteer
i learned a lot about a lot of different
causes but it was really only when i got
to fairy good mothers that i realized
this is the thing that i want to do
for a little bit longer
now jenna you've actually been with very
good mother since 2014 so tell us really
how this whole organization really works
out
yeah so it gives away prom dresses to
young people who can't afford them and
it's not necessarily just about a dress
it's really about in making sure the
confidence and self-esteem that people
can have
is coming out in one particular moment
wow that's so cool
so jenna tell me what's been the most
rewarding thing
big part of this program
i think the it's those moments that i
was talking about because we would have
little times when
somebody would interact you would see
somebody when they found their perfect
dress
stand up straighter interact more with
somebody they would talk differently and
i mean i remember one time when there
was a girl who came through the shop
and she got to the checkout area and she
was so serious and she was very
emotional
and she said this is the very first day
i've ever felt beautiful
and to us that meant so much but you
know one of our board members said no
this is this is the first day that
you've ever seen it
and
it's moments like that like somebody
remembers that for a really long time oh
yeah it touches your heart right yeah
well we wanted to um help you out today
and um our way of helping out was
reaching out to david's bridal and they
are donating ten thousand dollars to
fairy godmothers
only that
they are donating 300 prom dresses to
you and that is a gift that's worth 80
000
wow
that's amazing
i love that yeah so much well thank you
for building it and thank you sandy and
miles for doing this most important
story with us and jenna i just i i hope
this helps i know it's going to work
thank you david's bridal thank you thank
you so much
and to learn more about the fairy good
mothers this beautiful organization
please go to our website at the
drewberrymart show.com
miles and sandy i love you guys so much
great job
may this be the first of so many stories
we do together
[Music]